the black king would actually be
paralyzed but it wouldn't be in check
that would end in a draw but the good
thing is because white because black has
a light square bishop
you can't actually sacrifice it you
can't force white to take that light
square bishop
okay black attacking white's bishop
there now and that will just step back
white's king can defend it as well
all white needs to do he needs one move
he needs to much his f pawn forward one
of those doubled pawns
he's going to become a queen or at the
very least it will cost black his bishop
yes and the white king can now come into
the game and ably support its bishop
okay he steps back with a bishop
not a problem and now after rook takes
pawn
maybe black can go yay wanna pawn but
that doesn't really mean too much picky
sadly like you said it's all about white
pushing oh yeah mate was coming along
this dark square diagonal so ferruccio
resigns yeah alright
losing the first game here in the
semifinals artemia with a white piece is
fantastic play and he is up by one point
now after one game in the first
semifinal match